[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش في ثانيه اهم
تدريب عسكريا مشترك كما وصفه مراقبون ذلك
الذي اجرته الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
جنوب تل ابيب والهدف منه قصف اهداف تحاكي
مواقع نوويه ايرانيه في الوقت الذي باتت
فيه انشطه ايران النوويه هي المعضله
الرئيسيه التي زادت من حده التوتر بين
طهران والغرب اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه الفعليه عن بدء تدريب المشترك
مع الجيش الاسرائيلي في شرق البحر المتوسط
المناورات المشتركه تحاكي الهجوم على
مواقع النوويه ايرانيه وهدفها يقتصر على
تحديد الجاهزيه القتاليه للقوات المشاركه
وفق تقديرات الجيش الاسرائيلي تعتبر هذه
المناورات العسكريه هي الاضخم خلال عقدين
الاخيرين وتعدد الثالثه في غضون فقط
مراقبنا يرون ان وعشان تسعى عبر هذه
الخطوه لتاكيد الالتزامها منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
ما يتعلق بضمان الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه فمن خلال هذه التمرينات تدربت
القوات المشاركه على نموذج هجوم محتمل على
ايران بمشاركه الاف الجلود ومئات المعدات
القتاليه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القدس عبر
سكايب دكتور ماهر مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه ومن واشنطن
الدكتور دماغ غريبه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بكم مع ضفايا واسم حالي ان
ابدا من القدس معك دكتور مصري في الواقع
مفاجئ همم نشر هذه الصور يراها الباص خطوه
نحو التصعيد فيما البعض يراها بانها
تدريبات همم
بروتينيه ولكن حتى وان كانت تدريبات
الروتينيه لماذا نقاط
مستوحات من همم مراكز ايرانيه هل هناك شيء
يطبخ
شكرا على الاستضافه استاذه ريم تحياتي لك
والضيفك الكريم
اولا هي ليست العمليه التدريبات المشتركه
الاولى التي تحاكي تدخل
عسكري في الداخل الايراني بين اسير
الولايات المتحده كان اوبريت في السابق
كذلك تدريبات من نفس النوع ولكن في منطقه
اخرى ومن مشاركه حلفاء اقفليين
وبالتالي هذه ليس المره الاولى ولكنها
بالطبع ليست عمليات روتينيه نعم انا اقول
انه هناك استعداد وليس رضع وليست محاوله
رضع ليست ارسال رسائل وانما استعداد
للقيام بعمل عسكري غير مضبوط في العمق
الايراني
لتدمير البرنامج النووي الايراني ذو
الطابع العسكري هناك اليوم تطور في الموقف
الامريكي تطور غير مطبوخ منذ العام 2012
لكل الذين يدعون بان اسرائيل تحتاج الى
ضوء اخضر من الولايات المتحده وانها لم
تحصل على هذا الضوء او انه هناك خلافات
انا اقول انه منذ البدايه
انك تطابق في الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه بين
اورشليم القدس واشنطن فيما يتعلق بالطاعات
مع الخطر النووي الايراني ولكن كانت هناك
خلافات فيما يتعلق بالبعد التكتيكي كانت
هناك ثلاث خلافات اسرائيل تعتبر انه
المفاوضات العباسيه لن تؤدي الى شيء وانه
من الافضل تدخل العسكري من التوقيع على
اتفاق غير مرضى ومنقوص اسرائيل كذلك تعتبر
ان القطر النووي الايراني يتمثل في اقتراب
النظام الايراني من العتبه النوويه وليس
حصوله على سلاح النووي كما اا تعرف يتم
تعريفه واشنطن بالتحديد النووي الايراني
وثا انه اسرائيل تعتقد انه لو كان يجب ان
تكون هناك ان يكون هناك تدخل فالافضل ان
يكون الان الان لانه اسرائيل اليوم مستعد
اكثر من اي وقت مضى فبالتالي مضيعه الوقت
المحاوله تعتبرها كانت في السابق كسبا
للوقت تعتبره ادارا للوطن كانت خلافات
تكتيكيه وبالر
لما التقارب بين طرفين فيما يخص هذه
النقاد دكتور ادمان ضيف يتحدث عن ان
المفاوضات كانت مفاوضات عبثيه يقول بان
وكان هناك شيء جديد وكانه هناك خطوه جديده
من الجانب الامريكي تجاه همم ما يحدث في
داخل الايراني
الاداره الامريكيه قد وصلت تقريبا الى
طريق مصر في ما يتعلق بالمفاوضات مع ايران
هذا ما تقوله على الاقل الاداره الامريكيه
المسؤولون انه حتى الان في الوقت الذي لا
يريد القول بانه قد انتهت او المفاوضات
الا انهم همم يقولوا بان طريق مسدود وانه
لا يوجد الان اي مطابقه وبالتالي فانا
هناك مستوى اا جديد وصلت اليه العلاقه بين
الاولاد المتحده وايران بالاضافه الى ذلك
قلق امريكي من التقارب الروسي الايراني
ومن التقارب الصيني الايراني وهذا مقلق
للولايات المتحده ولذلك
هل هو مقلق لدرجه تحرك ما تحرك عسكري
لا اعتقد اننا لازلت استبعد ان نرى تحرك
عسكري من قبل الولايات المتحده ضد ايران
في هذه المرحله اعتقد ان ما نراها حاليا
اولا هذه المناورات هي مناورات كانون
المفترض ان يقام معروف
[موسيقى]
كان من المفترضا تعقد في 22 او في اواخر
شهر مارس اثار الماضي وبالتالي فانه اجلت
لاسباب
ويبدو انها الان وهذه الرساله من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه من ناحيه هي نوع من
الاعتراف الرسمي لان اسرائيل هي الان ايضا
جزء من الشريك في سنه بينما كانت قبل همم
مناورات تاتي تحت القياده الاوروبيه ولذلك
هذا تطور جديد هذه المناورات على مستوى
كبير فعلا تشترك فيها الطائره الامريكيه
تشترك فيها عشرات طائرات الاسرائيليه
يشترك فيها الاف جنود الامريكيين وحوالي
اكثر بقليل من الف جندي اسرائيلي اذا هي
رساله واضحه ما هي هذه الرساله هل الرساله
هي انها فعلا سنرى نرى الان بانها
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ستخططان لهجوم
على ايران
اعتقد انه ربما قد تكون هناك قطط في حال
حدوث حرب او رغبه بدون شك هناك رغبه
اسرائيليه منذ زمن بعيد
كامله من الجانب الامريكي ما رايك دكتور
همم ضيف يقول بانه حتى وان كانت المخاطر
الايرانيه تتصاعد شيئا فشيئا وعشان على
يقين ومدركه بذلك ولكن همم تحرك العسكري
ليس همم مطروح في هذه المرحله همم حضرتك
تتفق بان هذا همم
سيناريو مستبعت
لا انا لا اخون انه مستبعد ولكن لا شك في
انه الولايات المتحده ليست لا تعتقد انه
هذه هذه هي اللحظه
المواتير تماما الولايات المتحده انتقلت
من مرحله
الرغبه في الطفاوي بكل باي ثمن الى
التلويح بالخطباء
واليوم واسرائيل تحاول طبعا ان تقنع
الولايات المتحده بالتقدم والتطوير موقفها
لذهاب الى مواجهه عسكريه وتدخل في داخل في
العمق الايراني لانه لماذا لانه اولا
اسرائيل تعتبر انه هذه اللحظه المواطنه
التاجيل قد يضر بالكفاءه وان الولايات
المتحده تعتبر انه ربما ليس هذا هو الوقت
الافضل وربما هناك
للعوده مره اخرى الى طاوله المفاوضات لان
لي سبب بسيطه هو انه مره اخرى التعريف
بتهديد الايراني مختلف نحن في اسرائيل
نعتبر ان ان ايران اصبح
ت تمثل تهديد نووي لانها قريبه للغايه من
الحصول على القنبله الوقت المتحده تعتبر
انه طالما ان لم تحصل على قنبله ذريه اذا
التهديد النووي همم لا يزال هناك اذا لا
تزال هناك خلافات على المستوى التكتيكي
ولكن الرؤيه
الشامله هي متطابقه تماما وهو انه لن يسمح
لنظام الايراني ان يحصل على القنبله
الذريه السؤال هنا كيف سوف يتعامل طهران
مع هذه المعطيات ومع تطور الموقف الامريكي
هل ربما يفضل النظام الايراني ان يتعرض
لضربات عسكريه من قبل اسرائيل وحدها او
اسرائيل وغيرها
على التنازل ربما من اجل بقاء السلطه ربما
الاعتبارات داخليه هناك الانظمه في السابق
فضلت التعرض لهامات من الانسياق
لكمازون في سبب نظامها صدام حسين على سبيل
المثال هو خير خير نموذج وبالتالي
قال انه الكره اليوم هي في ملعب الايراني
من الناحيه الاسرائيليه انا اعتذر منك
رغبه للذهاب الى مواجهه وانه حتى
لو زاد فيكون هناك احد اقصى من التنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده وحد ادنى من التورط
الامريكي في اي عمليه عسكريه تقوم بها
اسرائيل نعم دكتور اذا كان الجانب
الاسرائيلي كما يتحدث الان الدكتور مائير
همم يعني يطرح مخاوفهم من الجانب الايراني
في مرحله همم في هذه المرحله التي نعيش اي
ان اا لا يجب على ايران ان تتمكن من
الحصول على قنبله نوويه ولكنه يقول بان
وكان سقف همم اكثر ارتفاع بالنسبه له عشان
طن وعشان طن اا خطها الاحمر هو عدم التمكن
ايران من ان تحافظ يعني يمكن ان تحصل ولكن
لا يجب ان تصل الى هذه المرحله بالتحديد
هل تتفق مع ذلك همم
نعم اعتقد ان هناك
ايضا بعض القوه الامريكيه التي لها مواقف
تتطابق مع الموقف الاسرائيلي الى حد كبير
بحيث ان ايران اصبحت الان هي تقوم بعمليه
تخصيب بنسبه 60% وان ربما قال لديها
القدره كما اعلن بعض المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بان لديه الكره
هذا الكلام ولكن هناك هذه المخاوف موجوده
في نفس الوقت ايضا الذي نشره في هذا
الكلام هناك اسئله مثلا اليوم بعد احد
كبار المسؤولين السابقين في الوكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه اطفال عن راي همم
هذه المناورات فقال بدون شاكر ان هذه
المناورات ستجلب الاختبارات همم رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ولكنني لا ارى اين هي
المصلحه الامريكيه فيها
ومن ولا استطيع ان لم يفسر لنا احد ما هي
مصلحه امريكا في القيام بذلك خاصه ان هذه
المناورات سيكون لها ردود فعل عكسيه
وسلبيا على المنطقه ولا اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده لها مصلحه في الدخول في حرب جديده
هذا ما قاله
وهو ايضا باحث الان في مركز تونسي ولكن في
نفس الوقت اعتقد هناك لبعض النقاط المهمه
التي اثارها ايضا الجنرال السابق جيمس
تبريدس وهو قائد قوات ماتوا في في اوروبا
قال بانها هذه المناوره
قال ان التخطيط للحرب فهو طريقه جيده لمنع
الحرب وقال ان هذه المناورات قد تساعد على
رجع قيام ايران بمغامرات في المنطقه وعلى
حزب الله بتفادي بقيامه بمشاكل وابعاد
القوات السوريه كما قال عن حدود اسرائيل
وبالتالي فهو رساله
مهمه اي ان الاعداد للحرب هو افضل طريقه
لمنع الحمل
هذه المناورات وكيف ستتفاعل كذلك معها
الاوساط الايرانيه او شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر
من واشنطن الدكتور ادم غريب الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه ومن القدس دكتور ماهر
المصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه